Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, je filme à l'extérieur parce qu'il recommence à faire beau en
France.
Il y a eu beaucoup de pluie récemment et il y avait même beaucoup d'alerte
orange,
voire d'alerte rouge, sur la partie ouest de la France, notamment à cause
d'innondation.
Mais là, j'ai l'impression que c'est le retour du printemps.
Donc je peux filmer dehors.
Je ne sais pas si vous allez entendre les voitures ou les oiseaux mais bon,
c'est un test.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui est les tests, les
examens de langue.
Parce que souvent, quand on apprend une langue, on a envie de passer un
test
pour un peu valider notre niveau.
Personnellement, j'apprends le japonais et en japonais, le test s'appelle
le JLPT.
C'est un peu l'équivalent du CECRL en français, sauf que ça s'appelle le
JLPT et il y a 5 niveaux.
Il y a le niveau 5, 4, 3, 2, 1 et du coup, le niveau 1, c'est le meilleur
niveau.
Avant de partir au Japon en 2024, je crois, en décembre 2022 ou en décembre
2023, je ne sais plus vraiment.
Non, c'est en décembre 2022, pardon.
J'avais passé le JLPT N3 et j'avais réussi avec un peu de chance.
Ce niveau N3, en gros, ça me donnait un niveau équivalent A2 B1 avec les
tests CECRL, comme pour le français.
En Europe, on utilise beaucoup ces niveaux A1, A2, B1, B2, C1, C2.
Du coup, avant de partir au Japon, il y a maintenant 3, 4 ans, j'avais
passé un niveau qui disait que j'étais niveau A2, B1 environ.
Et là, au Japon, mais même après maintenant, j'ai eu envie de continuer de
passer les tests et notamment de passer au niveau N2.
Parce que si je passe le niveau N2, j'aurais un équivalent niveau B2 en
japonais, ce qui est plutôt pas mal.
Et l'objectif final, c'est toujours de passer le niveau maximal, qui est le
niveau N1, qui, selon les points, peut correspondre à un niveau C1.
Donc si j'ai beaucoup de points au test, je peux avoir un équivalent niveau
C1.
En fait, ça, c'est un peu des objectifs, mais il y a la question de savoir
est-ce que c'est utile.
Et pour ça, j'ai une petite anecdote, c'est que, du coup, quand on était au
Japon, on était allés dans une librairie acheter des livres pour les tests
du JLPT.
Donc en plus, comme c'est au Japon, les livres étaient moins chers.
Et j'ai acheté trois livres.
J'ai acheté un livre de grammaire pour le JLPT N2.
J'ai acheté un livre de reading comprehension, donc de compréhension de
lecture, donc de compréhension de texte, pardon.
Et un dernier livre qui est des exercices de vocabulaire, de grammaire,
etc.
J'ai acheté ces livres, et en rentrant en France, bon, j'ai commencé un peu
à travailler, mais je ne me suis jamais vraiment inscrit au test.
Donc pour l'instant, je n'ai pas encore travaillé sérieusement.
Mais sauf qu'un jour, il y a des amis japonais qui sont venus en France, et
mon ami a commencé à feuilleter, donc à tourner les pages.
Il a feuilleté le livre de grammaire N2, et il m'a dit "Hum, on n'utilise
jamais ça, on n'utilise jamais cette grammaire".
Et du coup, là, je me suis dit "Est-ce que c'est vraiment utile de passer
ce genre de niveau ?".
Et du coup, je me suis dit c'est un bon sujet de vidéo, parce que bien
évidemment, vous apprenez aussi le français, et du coup, ça peut être une
question qui vous intéresse.
Du coup, est-ce que les tests sont vraiment utiles ?
Premièrement, en fait, avec cette anecdote de mon ami qui lit le livre et
qui se dit "On n'utilise jamais ces règles de grammaire",
ça pose la question de savoir est-ce que ce qu'on apprend, c'est vraiment
utile.
Un test, ça vise à tester des connaissances définies, une liste de
connaissances.
Souvent, cette liste de connaissances est définie par une institution
gouvernementale.
Je ne sais pas exactement qui, mais il y a des personnes qui disent "Ok, si
vous voulez un niveau C1 en français, il faut connaître telle règle, telle
règle, telle règle et telle vocabulaire".
Donc, c'est quelque chose d'assez académique et d'assez artificiel.
Quand on débute, c'est quelque chose de très utile.
Je pense que les niveaux A1, A2, B1, c'est des choses qui sont très utiles
parce que vous avez besoin de connaître les bases théoriques
pour pouvoir comprendre la langue, pour pouvoir faire de l'immersion et
pour aussi pouvoir vous exprimer.
Avec mes élèves qui débutent, par exemple, j'aime bien essayer d'arriver
rapidement à leur faire apprendre, à leur enseigner le présent, le futur
proche.
Je vais aller, ce week-end, je vais aller à Bruxelles, par exemple, le
passé composé.
Le week-end dernier, je suis allé à Bruxelles et l'imparfait, donc le temps
du passé pour décrire des choses.
En fait, quand on maîtrise, enfin quand on connaît ce genre de temps-là,
déjà on peut comprendre beaucoup de choses parce qu'on peut parler au
futur, au présent, au passé.
Bien évidemment, il existe des choses plus complexes, mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que les bases théoriques, il y a une liste à connaître.
C'est-à-dire que si vous ne connaissez pas ces temps, vous n'allez pas
pouvoir comprendre des grosses parties de la langue.
Et ça, je pense que, du coup, ce genre de test, un peu académique, c'est
très utile quand on débute parce qu'on valide un peu les bases théoriques
nécessaires.
Et après, en fait, plus on avance, moins c'est évident, moins c'est utile,
je pense.
Par exemple, en français, plus vous avancez, plus vous allez commencer à
apprendre des conjugaisons assez spéciales.
Je peux prendre l'exemple du subjonctif présent.
C'est un temps qu'on utilise quand même souvent.
Sur mon autre chaîne jeux vidéo, quand je joue jeux vidéo, je me rends
compte que souvent je dis, ah, il faut que je fasse ça.
Aujourd'hui, il faut que j'aille là-bas, etc.
Et tout ça, c'est du subjonctif présent.
Donc c'est un temps qui est quand même utilisé, mais ça commence déjà à
être utilisé dans des cas spécifiques.
Et après, si on va plus loin, on va avoir, par exemple, le passé simple.
Le passé simple, simple past, c'est tout, sauf simple.
Et en fait, quand je me pose la question, est-ce que c'est nécessaire de
connaître le passé simple pour des apprenants, pour des personnes qui
apprennent le français ?
Ben finalement, en fait, je me dis, mais en fait, les français ne
connaissent même pas le passé simple.
Et là, il y a une petite différence à faire.
Il y a une différence à faire entre la connaissance active et la
connaissance passive.
La connaissance passive, c'est quand on regarde, c'est la compréhension.
Donc quand on lit, quand on regarde une vidéo, on fait appel à nos
connaissances passives.
Et ça, c'est la raison pour laquelle, souvent, vous vous dites, ah, mais je
comprends mieux que je ne parle.
Je comprends mieux le français que je peux parler le français.
Et ça, c'est tout à fait normal, parce qu'on commence par les compétences
passives, les connaissances passives.
Mais ça, c'est pareil, en fait, pour les français.
Il y a une étude, mais je n'ai plus les chiffres exacts, mais qui dit qu'en
gros, une personne native en connaissance active,
ou compétences actives, c'est la même chose, elle va utiliser 5 à 10 000
mots de vocabulaire, 5 à 10 000 mots de vocabulaire.
Mais en connaissance passive, elle va connaître 30, 40 000 mots de
vocabulaire.
C'est-à-dire que finalement, on reconnaît beaucoup plus de choses qu'on
utilise.
Et ça, pourquoi je dis ça ?
Pourquoi je dis ça ?
C'est justement pour cette question du passé simple.
En fait, si vous demandez à un français de parler au passé simple, il va
avoir des difficultés.
Il va connaître des verbes principaux, par exemple « être ».
Ah, l'année dernière, je fus en Italie.
Donc ça, c'est le passé simple.
On connaît en général ces verbes principaux parce que c'est les verbes
qu'on voit le plus souvent.
Mais en fait, ce passé simple, on ne le retrouve que dans la littérature,
on ne l'utilise jamais.
Et en fait, le passé simple, même pour les natifs, ce n'est pas vraiment
une compétence active.
Ce n'est pas vraiment une connaissance active, c'est plus une connaissance
passive.
Et en fait, si vous arrivez à un test de français et que les personnes vous
demandent de conjuguer un verbe au passé simple,
en fait, même les natifs, ils auraient du mal à répondre à ce genre de
questions.
Et bon, je ne sais pas à quoi correspondent les tests C1 ou C2, par
exemple, en français,
mais il y a des choses comme ça que les natifs ne maîtrisent pas et que
parfois, on peut demander, je pense,
qu'en ayant juste une vision théorique, on peut demander aux apprenants de
connaître certaines règles.
Un autre exemple beaucoup plus fréquent, je ne sais pas si vous entendez la
voiture, je vais attendre.
Un autre exemple beaucoup plus fréquent, c'est l'accord du participe passé.
Donc quand on parle au passé composé, on utilise être ou avoir plus un
participe passé.
Et là, en fait, il y a une petite règle d'écriture.
Donc ça ne change pas la prononciation, mais ça change l'écriture.
Quand on utilise "avoir", par exemple, hier j'ai chanté une musique, chanter,
à la fin, ça s'écrit juste avec "é" accent aigu.
Donc juste chanté, ça a toujours la même écriture.
Mais quand on utilise, ah non, pardon, pardon.
Vous voyez, même moi, je vais reprendre mon explication.
Quand vous utilisez "être , je vais commencer par être.
Quand vous utilisez être, le participe s'accorde toujours avec le sujet.
Donc par exemple, hier je suis venu.
Donc moi je suis un homme.
Donc venu, à la fin je vais l'écrire, v e n u, juste u.
Si c'est une femme ou quelque chose d'objet ou un nom féminin, on va
accorder, on va m'écrire u e.
Hier, ma femme est venue, venue, v e n u e.
Si vous oubliez le e, c'est une faute, attention.
Et si c'est féminin et pluriel, on va écrire u e s.
Hier, mes soeurs sont venues, elles sont venues, v e n u e s.
Si vous oubliez ça, c'est une faute.
Vous commettez une faute de Français et c'est terrible.
C'est tellement terrible que beaucoup de Français font la faute.
Beaucoup de Français font cette faute à l'écrit parce que c'est un peu ce
qu'on appelle une erreur d'inattention.
C'est-à-dire que c'est des choses où il faut faire attention pour être sûr
de ne pas faire la faute.
Le problème, c'est que quand on écrit tous les jours des messages, on ne
fait plus vraiment attention à ce genre de règles.
Quand vous voyez "être", vous vous dites qu'il faut toujours accorder le
participe avec le sujet.
Pour "avoir", c'est plus compliqué.
Pour "avoir", le truc de "avoir", c'est qu'il y a toujours un complément
d'objet.
Par exemple, j'ai mangé des pommes.
Ici, des pommes, c'est ce qu'on a mangé, c'est le complément d'objet.
Et en fait, pour "avoir", la règle est encore plus difficile.
Parce que si le complément est après le verbe, on n'accorde pas.
Si il est avant le verbe, on accorde.
Et par exemple, je vais dire les pommes que j'ai mangé.
Manger, je vais l'écrire M, A, N, G et E accent aigu.
Je n'accorde pas.
Si je dis les pommes que j'ai mangées hier,
ici je dois écrire M, A, N, G, E accent aigu, E, S.
Si je n'écris pas ça comme ça, c'est une faute.
Et en disant ça, j'ai très peur de faire une faute en expliquant ça.
Donc après, quand je vais faire le montage vidéo,
je vais vérifier que mon explication est la bonne.
Donc tout ça pour dire, c'était une longue explication,
mais tout ça pour dire que parfois je pense que les tests
vont vous demander des connaissances actives
alors que pour la majorité des Français par exemple,
ce sont plus des connaissances passives.
Et ça, au bout d'un moment, ça ne devient plus vraiment utile
parce qu'on vous demande des choses tellement spécifiques
que dans la vie de tous les jours, ça ne sera plus utile.
Le passé simple, je n'utilise jamais le passé simple.
Le seul moment où je vois du passé simple, c'est quand je lis.
Et quand je lis, si je vois que l'histoire est au passé,
que le temps utilisé, c'est le passé et qu'il y a un verbe un peu bizarre,
je me dis "Oh, ça, c'est du passé simple".
Mais c'est tout.
Et par exemple, dans le cadre du travail,
dans la vie de tous les jours, dans n'importe quel cas,
je n'utilise jamais le passé simple.
Donc ça, à un moment, il faut se poser la question
"Est-ce que les tests vérifient des connaissances utiles?".
Vous pouvez bien sûr être très intéressé par la langue en elle-même,
par la langue dans toute sa théorie.
Et là, il n'y a pas de problème.
Mais si votre objectif, c'est d'avoir un niveau courant,
un niveau fluent, là, il faut se poser la question.
Et il faut faire la différence entre
"Est-ce que je veux que ce soit une connaissance active
ou une connaissance passive?".
Si vous voulez juste que ce soit une connaissance passive,
alors lisez des livres et essayez d'identifier les verbes au passé simple.
Et ce sera suffisant.
Donc voilà, je pense que l'utilité, déjà, c'est...
Elle est plus évidente, on va dire, quand on débute.
Plus on est débutant, plus passer un examen, ça va être utile.
Plus on a un niveau avancé, moins ça va devenir utile.
Et après, il y a un autre point qui est que,
mine de rien, ça reste un objectif.
Personnellement, je pense que je vais finir par passer le niveau N1 du
japonais,
parce que ça reste pour moi un objectif.
Je sais que j'apprends le japonais avec comme objectif de passer ce test.
Certes, ce n'est pas vraiment utile.
Oui, ce n'est pas vraiment pratique ou utile,
mais moi, ça me donne envie de continuer d'apprendre une langue.
Et ça, c'est important.
Si vous vous sentez démotiver,
même si vous avez un niveau avancé,
peut-être que vous pouvez vous fixer un objectif
de passer un test plus avancé.
Et ça, ça va vous pousser à essayer de consommer plus de contenus,
des contenus différents, parce que les tests,
ils demandent un vocabulaire assez large.
Et du coup, parfois, récemment, il y a une vidéo de Steve Kaufman,
donc qui est un GOAT de l'apprentissage des langues,
qui dit qu'il faut varier le type de contenu qu'on regarde.
Et ça, quand on va passer un test, on est un peu obligé de faire ça.
C'est-à-dire que je suis obligé de regarder des actualités politiques,
de l'économie, du divertissement, des choses très différentes,
parce que j'ai besoin de varier mon vocabulaire
pour avoir un vocabulaire le plus riche possible.
Du coup, ça, avoir cet objectif, ça peut nous pousser
à élargir un peu notre apprentissage.
Et sur le ... Quand on est sur le plateau intermédiaire.
Parfois, je pense qu'on a tendance à un peu faire toujours la même chose
et ne pas varier la manière d'apprendre.
Donc ça, c'est très utile.
Et le dernier point très utile, je trouve, c'est la concentration.
Pourquoi la concentration ?
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, la concentration, c'est quelque chose de très
précieux.
On est tellement stimulé tout le temps avec nos téléphones,
avec les notifications, etc
qu'on perd un peu cette capacité de concentration.
Tous les jours, je fais de l'immersion.
Tous les jours, je revois mes flashcards.
Et dès que j'ai une notification,
j'ai tendance à partir sur Instagram,
à partir sur TikTok, sur YouTube, etc.
Et ça, en fait, c'est un vrai problème,
parce que la concentration, c'est primordial
pour apprendre, pour progresser.
Et en fait, pourquoi un test, c'est intéressant pour ça,
c'est que un test, vous êtes assis sur une chaise sans rien,
pendant deux heures, trois heures ou quatre heures, je ne sais pas.
Et vous avez un texte dans la langue devant vous,
vous avez des questions sur la langue devant vous,
et vous ne pouvez rien faire d'autre,
à part réfléchir sur ces questions.
Et ça, c'est hyper important,
parce que c'est dans ce genre de moments de vraies concentrations
qu'on apprend vraiment à apprendre la langue,
qu'on apprend vraiment la langue, plutôt.
Parce que si on fait les choses à moitié,
en regardant à droite, à gauche,
ce n'est pas utile pour apprendre.
Et ça, j'avais fait l'expérience quand j'étais au Japon.
Un moment, on était, avec ma femme,
on était allés dans une sorte de bibliothèque pour travailler.
Et dans la bibliothèque, il n'y avait pas un bruit.
Il n'y avait juste une table avec ce pourquoi on travaillait.
Et on avait travaillé une heure ou deux.
Et juste travailler comme ça en étant vraiment concentré,
j'étais ressorti.
Je ne sais pas comment dire,
mais c'était vraiment un sentiment agréable.
Là, j'étais vraiment investi dans ce que je faisais,
j'étais vraiment concentré sur ce que je faisais.
Et je ne sais pas, il y a un peu une sorte de calme et de satisfaction
à vraiment se concentrer sur quelque chose.
Je vais peut-être un peu loin,
mais c'est peut-être un peu comme de la méditation.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous passez un examen
et que vous devez réfléchir pendant 4 heures sur un sujet,
on arrive à un sentiment un peu méditatif
où on est pleinement concentré sur un sujet.
Et ça, pour ça, je trouve que passer un examen,
se concentrer sur quelque chose de précis,
c'est très intéressant.
Donc voilà.
Ma réponse, finalement, c'est que oui, ce n'est pas utile,
et en même temps, c'est utile.
La règle d'or, je pense, c'est qu'il faut faire
ce que vous avez envie de faire.
Si vous pensez que ça peut vous aider à progresser
dans votre apprentissage, inscrivez-vous à un test.
Si vous sentez que vous n'en avez pas besoin,
alors ne le faites pas.
Ne perdez pas votre temps et votre argent.
Mais voilà.
Posez-vous la question, pourquoi est-ce que je veux faire un test
et vous trouverez sûrement la bonne réponse.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Je ne sais pas si elle est longue,
parce que d'ici, je ne vois pas le minuteur de la caméra,
mais j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Et je vous dis à la prochaine.
Je finis juste avec le Patreon.
Vous avez le script complet de cette vidéo sur mon Patreon.
Il faut juste créer un compte
et vous pouvez accéder gratuitement au script.
Et si vous voulez me soutenir financièrement,
vous pouvez le faire, c'est 4 euros par mois.
Merci aux quatre personnes qui me soutiennent.
Et je vous dis à la prochaine.